bonjour alors je vois à mon avis car ces
morts qui arrive une fois de plus mieux
jouer encore un bon petit tour je vous
demande d'attendre quelques secondes
alice a côtoyé voulez pas vous déranger
deuxième petit tous ses ennemis m bales
régal but non mais cela s'est fait alors
la petite balle ovale amène droite non
la droite mais la droite un nom aux
cessions dont on craint fort que moi
c'était le gouffre mal aménagé par une
autre balle égale bien oui il est levé
le pouce il est fait comme ça passe au
dessus doucement très doucement les deux
balise sont là
non mais c'est pas ça ce qu'ils
voulaient faire parce que ménage à faire
entrer cinq balles las une beauté 5,5
bal avec froid mais tous y reconnaître
une pièce de 5 francs la bouteille
y a rien dedans non élue référente et la
pièce de regarder at-elle son étape 1 2
et voilà comme alors ça franchement là
ça c'est une poêle à fait sûr tu es sûr
je veux pas sorti ah oui il m'a touché
bravo garcimore vraiment bravo vous nous
expliquerez quand même tout à l'heure
j'arrive à comprendre quelque chose
comme au moins un tour dans cette
émission
bon je l'étais ou là
[Musique]